[Música]
le voy a hablar pues de un programa que
me apasiona
que siempre comparto con mis trabajos en
la universidad y voluntariamente pues le
pongo mi corazón mi esfuerzo el programa
de la biblio mula que la universidad
tiene desde el año 2004
esto es un programa sencillo un programa
que se basa en tres objetivos tres
elementos fundamentales uno es el libro
este libro ustedes todos lo conocen
saben lo que es un libro y también
podrían tener unos conceptos
extraordinarios del libro nosotros en el
equipo de bibliomulas escogimos uno un
concepto y el concepto de jorge luis
borges que dice que el invento más
extraordinario más asombroso que ha
tenido el hombre es el libro los demás
inventos son extensiones del hombre
entonces dice por ejemplo el microscopio
y el telescopio son extensiones del ojo
el teléfono atención del oído el arado y
la espada extensión del brazo pero el
libro es otra cosa el libro es la
extensión de la memoria y de la
imaginación es el concepto nuestro del
libro lo otro es el concepto de
biblioteca hay de todo tipo de
bibliotecas pues hay bibliotecas o mejor
el concepto de biblioteca de uno solo
tener y mantener los libros
y hay de todo tipo de bibliotecas y
bibliotecas de textos históricos de
textos económicos religiosos políticos
hay bibliotecas circulantes hay
bibliotecas móviles
esta es la biblioteca móvil es el
segundo elemento el tercero elemento
fundamental de la biblio mula es la mula
la mula es un animal híbrido que nace de
la yegua y un burro un asno
y allí sale ese nuevo animal que es
estéril no puede procrear se y además de
eso es uno de los animales más
- 2 - esbelto que el caballo pero más
fuerte que el caballo y más ágil que el
burgués
y es también un animal simbólico es un
animal que fue testigo del nacimiento de
jesús de nazaret y en los andes
venezolanos la mula ha sido también un
símbolo
la mula ha paseado todos estos estos
páramos de los andes venezolanos en la
campaña que hizo el doctor arnoldo
gabaldón cuando empezó a sanear con las
fumigaciones todos los los hogares
venezolanos así que la mula esta forma
parte de nosotros está en nosotros
bueno estos tres elementos el libro la
biblioteca la mula se juntan mágicamente
para conformar la biblio mula que junto
con los muleros
qué son los que llevan a las mulas los
propios maestros los niños los
promotores de las escuelas de la
animación de la lectura hacen que
mágicamente esos tres elementos sean
distintos pero tenemos unos libros
andantes una biblioteca andariega y una
mula un tanto rocinante porque nos lleva
a nosotros el sueño de esto y es un
sueño que trastoca todo esto que va por
allí en estos páramos
quería decirle otro otro dato adicional
la biblio mula desde el año 2002 comenzó
con tres escuelas y dos y dos mulas hoy
día tenemos 18 escuelas incorporadas al
programa y tenemos 5 mulas
esas mulas llegan a las escuelas sin
nombre llegan desnudas digamos y los
niños la bautiza con un nombre por
ejemplo cenizo y chiquito que son los
que viven aquí en este campus tempé
están aquí desde hace mucho tiempo son
compañeros de trabajo ya
está a una que se llama una mula que se
llama golondrina que es este que están
viendo ustedes arjen es la mula
golondrina los niños del amo coti le
colocaron el nombre está la una fórmula
que se llama princesa y hay otro que se
llama fraile jonás que fraile jona está
fuera del estado trujillo porque ya
hemos ido expandiendo un poco este mismo
cuchillo junto con unos amigos que nos
ayudan a animar la lectura y entonces
este programa ayuda a llevar libros a
las escuelas y las lleva a 18 escuelas
de unos de este valle del momboy sitios
de verdad inaccesibles hay un sitio que
hay que pasar el río el mismo riesgo la
misma quebradita 17 veces
hay chicos aquí que han ido con nosotros
voluntarios y saben lo que estoy
hablando sabe lo que significa montarse
en la mula y seguir avanzando y llevar
los libros hay 35 comunidades que
servimos en alrededor de esas escuelas y
hay además un alrededor de unos 75
maestros a los cuales son nuestros
aliados esas comunidades esos maestros
esos mil 50 alumnos a los que les
llevamos los libros en forma gratuita
muchos donados por ustedes muchos
donados por compañeros que conocen de
este programa esos libros se les
entregan a los niños los niños se los
llevan y hay una hermosísima algarabía
cuando llegan los niños a esta cuando
llegan los libros si quiere poner una de
las qué
esa alforja que está allí cuando la
colocamos y es algo así como esto miren
esta es la mula de boeing
y montarse aquí
así es
esta silla es debe ser de chiquito
porque vuelve bastante fuerte
cuando tú agarras esto y empiezas a
trasladar si queremos estaba rosalía por
favor
cuando empiezas a trabajar y subes estoy
en trinca dos caminos
cuando llegas eso que está ahí cuando
llegas a la escuela y haces esta magia
digamos
y colocas esos libros ahí y entregas los
libros y empieza ese contacto tan
hermoso porque recuerda que el objetivo
de la biblio mula no es llevar los
libros porque no tendría sentido lo
podríamos llevar en una caja es llevar
el libro y entrar en contacto con algo
extraordinario que se llama la animación
en la lectura y la animación de la
lectura el mejor objetivo es la lectura
misma no puede haber otra entonces
tenemos que tener unas capacidades unas
estrategias para que eso se dé entonces
animar la lectura significa buscar el
libro acertado hay libros que son con
figuritas entonces eso tiene que ver con
una edad y unos intereses hay otros
libros que ya no tienen figura y ese
paso de la no imagen a la imagen es lo
que da toda un proceso de seguimiento de
la lectura de animación a la lectura
y meterle en el corazón de los niños la
posibilidad de seguir leyendo
entonces tenemos que buscar un lector un
maestro que sea buen lector que tenga la
capacidad de embelesar a los niños
que los lleve a la primera etapa de esa
inicial que todos ustedes vivieron y yo
también de quedar embelesado con un
cuento que nos dieron los padres o los
hermanos antes de dormir
esa es una extraordinaria posibilidad
quien no le dice quien no le está en un
cuarto cerrado pero cuando tú comienzas
a leer comienza entonces a abrirse las
ventanas comienzas a ver los paisajes
comienzas a ver
tu propia libertad del mundo ese mundo
porque cada libro es un mundo y fíjense
ustedes que aquí puedo decirle que puedo
empatar con con toda la creatividad de
los seres de chame aquí se van cuando
vamos subiendo vamos pensando en
nuestros seres creativos que nos
permitan un poco asumir la posibilidad
de llegarle a los niños cuando llegamos
a abrimos la alforja y la algarabía se
se colocan esos niños gritando con los
libros
si no lo aprovechamos lo perdemos
fíjense un cuento el niño durmió debajo
del árbol
el bosque también durmió y soñó con él
el río cantaba entre la sombra verde se
vieron pisadas en la hojarasca y
aparecieron unos ojos llenos de
estrellas
si nosotros no empatamos no encajamos no
alquilamos el que será en los niños
hemos perdido pero si lo anclamos si el
niño está así y dice que será cuáles
serán esos ojos ahí hemos ganado y la
biblio mula regresa feliz y entonces ahí
hay la magia esta es la magia de este
sueño el que nosotros trabajamos con los
maestros el taller es para animación a
la lectura para en cuentacuentos incluso
en procesos creativos me diría yo que
también le damos esa buena posibilidad
porque tenemos desarrollo el pensamiento
y con los niños a enseñarnos a trabajar
la lectura a trabajar el libro a
analizarlo y eso sin duda qué va a ser
el gran sueño nuestro de que esas
generaciones de niños del campo van a
ser mejores que sus padres eso es sin
duda y esto es la tecnología que estamos
llevando ojalá que podamos seguir
pensando y creciendo en una ciber mula
en donde eso que vivimos aquí lo podamos
transportar muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]